hier nous vous parlions du salon vinexpo
à bordeaux qui reste ouvert aux
professionnels du vin jusqu'à vendredi
une bonne occasion de visiter les caves
du célèbre château d'yquem avec un guide
hors pair un maître chez qui vient de
prendre sa retraite après quarante cinq
ans d'activités plein d'arômes olivier
les nizza et dominique merlet
accroché sur le fil de l'éternité
yquem devenu propriété de la couronne de
france sous le règne de charles vii
un château qui protège un joyau
une étiquette blanche une chasse de
bouteilles une lumière d'or variant
d'intensité au gré des ans une essence
de soleil et de miel bercé par un enfant
du pays
alors là je vais vous montrer ne des
plus vieilles bouteilles qui existe dans
cette cave c'est du vin qui avait été
mis en bouteille pour ton nature
personnes c'est en
1784 vous avez goûté oui j'ai goûté la
petite soeur le maître de chai à droite
bouteilles de vin bien sûr c'est un peu
voir comment son travail et ses ancêtres
un gamin du sauternais ouvriers à 15 ans
devenu grand maître en 1970 le seigneur
du château qui prend sa retraite et les
femmes au travail
les gentils et pas un petit peu dur et
vous pourquoi dur
travail
de comptable un domaine 205 ha 70
salariés 95 mille bouteilles
commercialisées chaque année tiré à
peine un verre de vin par pieds de vigne
un jus qui doit titre et 20° 20 degrés
là où commence l'éternité d'yquem
c'est très joli il ya des gras plats qui
sont magnifiques elle s'étale bien elles
grossissent vraiment très très bien ces
grappes sont belles belles belles
évidemment jeunes observerait que de
ping pong ouais
mais offert cpie de vie n'ont pas tout à
fait fini de vous voir au rôti par le
soleil le raisin devient l'ombre de
lui-même et repose pendant trois ans
dans des barriques de chêne
je vais déguster cette barrique qui est
de 1996
je vais voir l'évolution qu'il a depuis
quelques jours un pouvoir si il va dans
le bon sens
ainsi pouvoir faire tout l'espoir que
nous avons donnés en lui c'est à dire un
très grand millésime
une offrande de la nature un sortilège
enivrant sortie d'une cave hanté pendant
un demi siècle par un petit homme tout
simple un petit homme devenu le temps
d'une vie le seigneur du château